okay here we are on overtime for the
last time this season let me pose to you
the questions that have been asked by
people writing it if you had unlimited
money and resources Michael Moore what
documentary would you make and why well
you do have unlimited money resources
whenever you have been stopped by that
um actually I would I would vanish don't
cost a lot of money yeah I think um I
think I would make a film about religion
religion you'd make Religulous -
wouldn't you now there but you know
there's a movie that opened today by a
documentary filmmaker by Alex Gibney
called maiya Maxima culpa about the
Catholic Church and the whole how the
not so much about the pedophile priests
per se but about how the cover-up took
place oh because the pedophile priests
are here or sick and who need help the
bishops who covered it up and move the
priests around they knew what they were
doing they weren't sick they broke the
law and it's stunning to me as a
Catholic that none of them are behind
bars right
okay ten days after the election does it
appear that the Citizens United decision
had no effect other than driving up the
cost of campaigning good question you
think that I mean we spent how much this
time
Oh billions and billions of billions of
dollars in the presidential race it had
obviously Obama overcame that in the
Senate races almost every single one the
targets of these super PACs won some of
the House races were different but I
thought it was really inspiring that
despite all this money that on there's
one day every four years or every two
years when everybody's got an equal say
and people came out and they basically
said to the billionaires and the
plutocrats and the special interest you
know what we're not doing it your way
we're gonna do it our way and that's
what that's what makes democracy
inspiring but it was good that the
Democrats were able to match them pretty
much and well you know but we we didn't
actually bill match them in money
despite the lavish donations of some
good friends but we didn't actually
match one o'clock yes we did but it is
concerning it's not a way we want our
politics to run in the future it
absolutely isn't don't you think that I
had something to do with a decreased
number of voters well first of all we
don't we'll see how many voters actually
voted there still actually counting
votes I let some states or yeah not just
Laura but all over the country I will
let me say two things about this first
of all we we have to fix our voting
system we can't have people in the
United States of America waiting seven
hours to vote that is something
that is something that we have to do and
I think in the the interestingly in the
States in those battleground states the
turnout was higher than it was four
years ago so the people were most
intensely involved in the campaign
actually came out and voted you know
where money really matters though like
we had a ballot initiative here to just
label what foods are genetically
modified it was just about don't you
want to know what you put in your mouth
just information and it was pulling it
like ninety percent approval rating
before the money got involved this is
where money really because when people
don't have hardly any information about
something at all and you have 30 days to
change their mind and of course in 30
days they poured all this nonsense on
the airwaves how you feel the same way
about the money that was poured in on
behalf of the marijuana initiatives they
were I spent what forty to one it was
the the pro-marijuana forces had
enormous a financial advantage but
people know about pot they don't know
that much about genetically modified
food that's the difference is that you
know it's so funny you mention that
because I remember when we were in
college smoking pot and we thought you
know what you remember that I do and I
remember sitting around in our dorm room
bull sessions and and we would say you
know what when we get to be 50 years old
and we're the establishment we're
running the show of course pot will be
legal cuz we smoked it now when we know
it's not harmful and yet it took all
this time and it's still only two states
that'll change personal store anyway
it's an obscene effect like uh gay
marriage people have changed their minds
about that very quickly since Oh for you
pretty much and yet that is on these two
okay Matt asks why why do you think that
when the u.s. uses a drone to target and
kill a terrorist it is celebrated but
when Israel targets and kills a
terrorist in the Gaza Strip following
weeks of rocket attacks they are
condemned very good question there
i cani oh really yeah I don't especially
to sending drones in or missiles to kill
civilians regardless who's doing it no
it's not is wrong and a lot of art a lot
of our drones have killed oh yes sattell
ulis but you know what Israel did that
was not a civilian that was a Hamas
commander I was a guy who's firing rock
that was well actually if you read if
you read the saurian in Hertz the
Israeli newspaper today that military
commander was secretly working with the
Israelis to broker a peace deal and he
had denied it - well you don't you don't
you disagree with what they wrote - no I
think you you have not you have to read
the rest of the story I mean you read
the top I read the whole story but it's
not there was that he had us I was a man
of peace I'm just saying there's there
he had some persimmons in hot lines but
he would made a drop position to him and
of course he wasn't there a people who
don't want peace to take place because
they're invested in war this is true all
around the world people are making money
off this and I think Mike Michaels part
of some of those people are the people
who are hailing Rockets over into Israel
and a regular basis Rockets are
uncovering themselves you know I mean
somebody sorry I'm not I I condemn all
else is non-negotiable Israel has a
right to defend itself
right yeah yes right every right right
and and certainly there should be a
broader solution obviously we also are
sympathetic to why people in the
Palestinian territories are living in
conditions they shouldn't have to live
in there should be a greater solution
and by the way in those conditions you
might be pretty pissed that's what I'm
saying and you might not be thinking
straight I and you may do things then I
am agreeing with that but I'm telling
you people like Mitt Romney who who say
you know what we have to be in complete
lockstep with Israel we could never even
criticize them they do not help Israel
and they do not help the peace process
that is blatant pandering to the to the
Jewish vote in America and by the way it
didn't work they
I know I know I know
Mitt Romney hates the minorities because
they both we weren't gonna mention his
name anymore
yeah that's a bit ago he whose name or
combination but you know what Voldemort
you know what yes great I wanted on
behalf of those who voted for President
Obama thank you Bill for what you've
done ro come on shoka the money I'm
serious we make a lot of jokes about the
million dollars but uh I have it just
just lying around I not a welcome hand
and
[Applause]
thank you Michael thank you
but it was a really fun season I've
[Applause]
Real Time with Bill Maher the returns
for a new season January 18th will ask
building his guests to have questions
right after the show
at hbo.com